hey i'm bobby newport i'm a regular guy
i like dogs
i'm here with my persian greyhound
raclette it was given to me by my buddy
the pretender to the crown of alsace
loren
how's it going i'm bobby newport but you
probably knew that already well mr
newport we meet at last i'm leslie knope
ah okie doke so do you want me to sign
that to ms lope or just nezny what
no i
leslie's fine leslie yeah miss knope is
a candidate for city council i've been
calling your office trying to set up a
debate oh no you guys are wrong i'm
running unopposed i'm pretty sure i'm
running unabose right
no you're not running unopposed you're
very opposed by me oh terrific i love
meeting people i love it
yeah what do you guys do
we we just told you we're gonna be
running for city council great here have
a bobby bar go ahead my dad made him
okay folks
hey i'm bobby newport i think we scared
him here i have a bomby bar my dad made
him i am leslie knope i love this town
and i've worked my whole life to make it
great
i believe that i've earned your vote
bobby newport believes he can buy it and
maybe that's because he's never earned
anything his entire life
that hurt my feelings hurt my feelings
you're supposed to be this positive
person can't we just talk about things
we like
well said uh just a reminder to our
candidates to keep it civil
looking at you leslie ah it's okay joan
i'm okay i'm just
i'm nervous man i'm nervous
god i guess i want to do a good job
because um i like it when people think i
do a good job and i want your vote
because i want pawnee and my dad to see
what i'm made of
so let's do this
[Applause]
the wrecking crew we let you guys in
hey jason
hey bobby
oh hi
want to play bowling
why don't you play with the real one
oh i like this one better
little guy looks like me
hey can we talk for a second
look i just wanted to say i'm really
sorry your dad died and i'm really
really sorry i called him a jerk
that's okay
he was like a million years old
and he was kind of a jerk
the only reason i did this campaign was
to impress him and he couldn't have
cared less
you know my mom was a great athlete when
she was a kid so in junior high i joined
the track team
to impress her
even though i hated it and at the end of
the year
i ran the 5 000 meters in this huge
track event and i
finished dead last
and i thought she was gonna be really
disappointed in me
but she wasn't she ran up to me and she
wrapped me up in this big hug and she
told me she had never been more proud of
me
thanks leslie that's a great story
i'm not 100 sure i get the point but you
finished this race bobby
the campaign is over and you finished
win or lose
i'd bet you anything that your dad was
proud of you
now i get it there you go your mom and
my dad are both dicks
mr newport hello hi
leslie knope ben wyatt yeah good miss
you nice to see you do you guys want
anything this is a restaurant so they
have food and stuff i'll take a
milkshake oh we're good
what can we do for you
yes um
why'd you guys post that video of me man
i mean that didn't make me feel good it
was it was mean you guys are mean
well we used your own ad so i i don't
think it was mean all right let me lay
it out for you my friends keep sending
me links to that video and they just
make fun of me it's just
stop running okay just
stop
stop running the ad no stop running the
campaign
what just quit it would be so cool of
you if you just quit
then i can win the election and i'll
have a big party and i'll put you both
on the guest list plus one
i'm gonna have a man who does magic he's
really good not like cheesy magic like
good magic we're not gonna
quit the campaign
why would we do that because
i want it come on give me it give me it
give me it
come on give me it just give me the
election i'm sorry please
please
well leslie he does make a compelling
argument come on uh come on
guy
bobby oh it's not padded i'm bobby
newport
my family owns nine square miles of land
in this town
and isn't my family what this town's
really about vote bobby newport the
reason why bobby and i are appearing
together is to send the message that
everyone should get out and vote no
matter who they're voting for that's
right another awesome point by leslie
that's why i'm voting for you
[Laughter]
what's so funny they're laughing at your
joke
what joe i am voting for you
you're not voting for yourself
leslie campbell for yourself i don't
think pretty sure that's illegal
this is my home
you are my family
and i promise you
i'm not going anywhere
holy leslie that was awesome
[Applause]
look at that thing what is that
don't touch it i know this if something
is dirty we should clean it up
let's start there
right
you know i i had this cleaning lady
named yolanda
who was very wise she basically raised
me and one day she said little bobby i'm
not gonna clean your room no moss and
from that day on my room was gross
really bummed me out i think we should
make our parks
look like my room after yolanda finally
you know gave in and cleaned it up for
me i'm an american
my father is an american my mother is an
american
my godfather is the viceroy of the
principality of liechtenstein hi i'm
bobby newport
my dad is friends with john cougar
mellencamp
that's pretty cool i guess i would like
to tell mr munchme that i think that
stinks that happened to him you know one
time a guy stole some downhill skis out
of my jeep and i was so mad i punched a
mailbox
i'm against crime and i'm not ashamed to
admit it
people keep asking me bobby what are you
gonna do once you get in office
um
i'm pretty sure i'll figure it out
bobby newports never had a real job
in his life um you gotta give it more
attitude it's gotta scare people
bobby newport yeah okay all right
bobby newports never had a real job
in his life
bobby newport's never had a real job in
his life bobby newport bobby newport
bobby newport bobby newport bobby
newport newport bobby
bobby newport right now we're just
wasting time jerry
you